cyber monday is tomorrow it's one of the
busiest days for online sales and some
businesses plan to cash in
and offer some deals 8 news now reporter
kristen drummond joins us live in our
newsroom tonight
with more on what we can expect kristen
sasha some businesses already posted
their cyber deals and
they're even going this entire week but
one company plans to participate for the
first time tomorrow
one way to try and adjust to the current
situation and customers needs
we've never done this before getting
ready for an online sale
cyber monday is always something i
thought like that wasn't like part of
our program
but the pandemic changed juani romero's
mind during the height of the pandemic
most of our coffee sales were coming
online for local delivery
romero owns sunrise coffee and
mothership coffee roasters a small
business with cafe locations around the
las vegas valley
she plans to offer a discount on coffee
bags and a gift box
only on the website during cyber monday
we came up with the concept of creating
a coveted safe
coffee present a trend as shopping
habits shift to online during the
pandemic
according to the retail association of
nevada and we are expecting an
increase in the number of shoppers who
say that they are going to be shopping
online this year
that's up 12 to 74 percent
up from 62 percent last year big
discounts may also entice customers to
scroll through potential savings at
hotels and casinos we've definitely
upped the ante for this year
station casino cyber sales are underway
the company is offering some sweet deals
at a couple properties we never put the
sweets on and we never put some of our
even our smaller suites on discounting
rooms to not only bring back locals
but visitors for the out of town people
we need to start getting them to come
back to las vegas
finding ways to boost business with
cyber sales while adapting to the
coveted circumstances
obviously like this whole year has
brought like a lot of new learning for
me
the retail association of nevada says
the word of the season is
uncertainty and that's because of our
high unemployment rate and how much
people may spend
not only online but at brick and mortar
stores